chapter 8 the magic trick  you are an aperture through which the  universe is  looking at and exploring itself  alan watts i want to know god's thoughts  the rest are mere details albert  einstein  the ultimate question why does reality  exist who are we  why are we here where did we come from  and where  are we going it's both hilarious  and infuriating watching our species  unable to account for our own genesis  the magician in the magic trick should  be our main  focus i think we are  the magician and created this reality  as consciousness exploring infinity  how deeply have you contemplated your  source  everyone is able to walk themselves back  the great chain of being in all roads  lead back  to the same source  we all share the same source that is  scientific evidence of oneness  you